[Music]
let me tell you whatever you want
yes but I have it's about this romance
novelist named Alicia she went to
Twitter and she talked about how she
went on this date with a guy and this is
what she said yesterday I met a guy for
coffee and he asked what I like to drink
and went and fetched the order and he
came back with two cakepops
and I was like oh that's so cute then he
ate both of them in front of me so he's
clearly a monster right and as you can
always a funny [ __ ]
she's in a thread it's a whole day
almost 24 hours later and I am still
marveling over this man who is on a date
and buys two whole cake flops which is
equal to the number of people on this
date and doesn't offer a single kpop
cake pop to said date I never want to
feel that way again
I should add the or Valentine's cake
pops with little hearts on them is she
going on the second date though I don't
know doesn't like her and he was just
like [ __ ] it through your head Bart got
doing bits like that on the first date
is destructive I know that I'm your head
people there know that it wouldn't work
Tommy it wasn't like he's funny what if
he got it and she's like I don't do
dairy here's where it's funny though you
know if he then after doing that goes
and gets you a cake pop then it's funny
yeah if you fix the situation yeah that
one in the back pockets me off so that's
what's weird to say he didn't yeah he
doesn't like her maybe he's oblivious
I think it's that cuz I think a lot of
guys are just a bit oblivious because
there's one person cause yeah he's not a
control then his one person quoted Maya
Angelou Angelou and said whence Angelou
ii when someone shows you who they are
believe them the first time you know
what I can't believe is that that is a
famous quote cuz it's so basic sounding
and yet that's really nice and profound
so I will sometimes I feel like the most
profound quotes are the basic [ __ ] that
use never you know yeah but what if you
have a bad read on someone yep they show
you who they are but
you're so stupid that you misinterpret
yeah I showed you exactly cuz a lot of
people like that too yeah so then other
people were ended up responding this guy
gave you an instant snapshot of what
married to him it's so basic cuz also
like I I've done things in a past
relationship where I didn't realize it
was [ __ ] up until I had the
conversation about it I realized I
pissed her off and then I learned
exactly four year old table manners dude
that is like awkward if you're gonna go
get food offer dude so me and Nikki
during Christmas season we always do
this thing called cooking party where
all of her friends from high school are
like two of her friends from high school
she doesn't have a lot of friends from
the piriformis you know so so she's had
many friends but these these few friends
come to this party that called the cold
cookie party okay so we're there and I
had just gotten Thai food Transco every
times we we were starving and her friend
showed up and as soon as they came in I
put the food down I'm starving
but I put the food down and I hide it
because I have manners
I can't [ __ ] eat around people that's
what I was Judy was drilled in my
[ __ ] head I sit there and just think
about how impolite I'm being if I'm in
front of them while they're not eating
yeah I won't do it but it could also be
cultural cuz there's [ __ ] I've eaten
with some people that burping is okay at
the table and I'm like what your [ __ ]
like it likes chewing with your mouth
open I'm like what listen those food
people are in every culture yes but
that's not cultural rude pisses rude
people that might be rude to you but it
might be cool trolls of that cultural to
be rude but that's not rude it's your to
uh burp the burping I mean you know in
some cultures when you burp her the
table it means you're having like a set
of gears and which cultures rude one
the rude culture tables Oh cousin I
think that's a standing ovation in
Chinese culture I heard if you get a
massage by a Filipino you tell them that
it feels good by farting okay so if
you're relaxed they're like oh yeah when
you part
you are side them MA okay
that's just beautiful culture that's all
right so it depends on the person yeah
like the slurping thing and rudeness but
in Japanese culture it's a great nose
where is it that's Steven no I'm just my
all my uncle's did all the things you're
talking about farting slurping oh but
that rude though they are really fun
thing gentlemen apparently they're
throwing a parade for the club that's
not you see that's one thing that's
jakey news for you know you were at a
Beijing politician party and everyone's
[ __ ] burping and farting I don't know
if that's like actual Chinese JP news
the only place where somebody goes yeah
well drink it through the straw that's
like a cultural thing and then people
are like [ __ ] talking about slurping
noodles though is a okay thing in Japan
yeah yeah cuz they say that they say
that when you when you slurp it it
tastes better right no no it's a
pleasant sound it's like oh that sounds
delicious
it's like going mmm my mom would beat
the [ __ ] out of me if she like Sonia do
that I feel like also my parents like
any type of noise in your mouth and
you're chewing or slippering they would
they definitely know they're also
Montana Montana anyway yeah more
responses to this people said that's the
type of monster who would it share a
floating door when the Titanic sinks cut
him loose hahaha
I mean aren't cakepop cakepops a
cultural thing my culture beautiful but
also everyone knows that two people
can't fit on that door so that metaphor
makes no sense nobody can will Rose
wouldn't do it she coulda scooted over I
know she's a [ __ ] the [ __ ] yeah
another reply says it's
when they wave those right flags so
bright no one said he's ready he's
definitely an airline seat definitely
read play definitely read what did that
person say white flags is surrendered to
them what did that person the red or
white well that's when they surrender so
so hard yeah I said what you said
well you said rights if I'm gonna be
gonna risk it right white right same
thing the actual tweet reads it's nice
when they wave those red flags so yeah
you should write flag so bright that's
what that's what happened Sally's making
sure it's so deeply into these things
it's crazy it's just one date I just
said white right same thing people gonna
read that too people do read deeply into
it but at the same time it feels my
first date with somebody and a girl
dissed me she like that like if she
brought let's say I don't know two
[ __ ] cookies yeah and was like and
just ate him in front of me I'd be like
mental note I'm gonna I would have
called it out or I would have just
grabbed well I wouldn't mean it'll be
like oh you know you're not going off
you know cookie I'm saying like what
both of what were yours yeah so
depending on how she reacted says a head
of explanation at Lavanya something what
if she was like you're like oh then for
sure either she's a [ __ ] oh she's
really funny and trying to she's working
the bit yeah positive thing I mean it's
the first date because what I used to do
too is um when I would be interacting
with somebody on like a like a first
time I would I would do things to gauge
how they would react to see if they were
cool I remember well that was the
relationship [ __ ] thing keys that we
did we talked about a while back yes
Bart's ready to go but are you ready for
this what Tim's about to say will be so
much more polite than what you say so go
ahead
it is I don't know you're gonna say but
one of my one of my best homegirls in
college to see if she was like annoying
or not like one of the first days were
him I was like man you're cool we should
move in together and I said that just to
see how she would take I always say that
and she stood and she started cracking
up and I was like all right she's cool
cuz I feel like I'm like blame people
would have said oh my god you're weird
it seemed legend with how our happened
when we got right but my take it too
seriously there's just too early for
this is really vanilla though yes he
farts like for cousin chickadees so see
yous ready for you he thought that you
were about to support his point was it
was his original plan you haven't even
one another was gonna [ __ ] himself in
front of her well yeah I mean you can
make any moves on me so I got zero well
I do it every day no cuz you have me now
Hart brings the kids toilet on a date
and he shits in it in front of you and
then and then he puts it to the side I
can't believe she reacted I mean yeah
he's staring at you like are you gonna
be a snake man well also like one of the
first times like the first night I ever
spent which year I might have told a
story before but like that night I was
like okay I'm gonna go just poo and
shower and then she's like okay cool and
the fact that she wasn't like oh my girl
so she wasn't like oh my god too much
information which is all right cool I
like this chick is my type of chick you
know
see I dude I had to diarrhea so bad on
one amazing his first date okay
but what I did was so we were playing
Smash Brothers in my living room right
and we was a tight game very sick for
Nintendo 64 the 64 version of the game
yeah yeah so I go into the bathroom
which by the way this entire apartment
was like 600 square feet oh my god she's
gonna hear and smell it all everything I
make sure the smell is on extra loud
yeah so that background musics like
popping always right it's popping off
you know what's going on though I go
inside the bathroom I immediately turn
on the sink I immediately open so don't
go and run no no hold on doesn't matter
well he opens the window like slowly so
it'll hear that thank you card thank you
and I wd-40 that [ __ ] before the day I
didn't okay so so then I do my thing
right did you get the shampoo and line
the bottom of the door so that way
there's a breeze
scent of the shampoo but now it's like
booby-trapped in the toilet so it like
splashes in there Oh No but that's by
the way that's really hot tip out there
just make sure you clean up after it
yeah or else they're gonna open the door
to slip in like a booby trap what do you
learn in [ __ ] oh sorry I keep smells out
yeah it's a spiritual thing do you know
so so then I go back in the room and it
was completely chill because there was
not annoy smell but you think no but it
was just running water but you know what
and I was a quiet diarrhea screams
people do that I judge them when it's in
water on you so it's rather waste water
then to vlog on live through the
embarrassment genomics water you waste
when you wash your [ __ ] jag wash it I
let the sprinklers now I always turn the
water on when I'm sitting at Anu like
what I think people can hear me yeah I
let it go I just hold it dude I'd rather
get a [ __ ] stomach hey listen if my
place was 4,000 square feet I'm walking
[ __ ] in to the other wing and
[ __ ] and I'm turning on the faucet
I'm an [ __ ] but 600 square feet I
think you prepared you should have been
prepared I was I didn't exist yet it
exists no poo pourri didn't exist y'all
to embarrass in Stars I should have done
it too embarrassed I thought it was wick
and [ __ ]
[Music]